I have committed zena but soon
afterwards I regretted my actions. Will
Allah forgive me or must I be flogged
100 times. Finally, I need advice on
becoming a better
Muslim. The question posed by a Nigerian
student is that he unfortunately
committed sinner and he repented and he
has
regretted. Will Allah forgive him?
Should he be flogged? Point number one.
If anyone commits a sin, he should
repent for it. And for repenting, there
are five criterias. And I've said this
earlier also. Number one, he should
agree what sin he's doing is
wrong. Number two, he should stop it
immediately. Number three, he should not
commit that sin again. Number four is he
should repent to Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala for that sin. Number five, if he
can undo it. For example, if he has
robbed something, he can give it back.
If the act is he has taken something and
can undo it, he should undo it.
Otherwise, it's okay. So the fifth point
is if he's dropped something, he should
give it back. Or if he cannot undo, it's
excused. So there are minimum five
criteria. First, agree it is wrong, stop
it immediately, not to do it again,
repent for it and ask Allah for
forgiveness. Something and can undo it,
you should undo it, otherwise it's okay.
So now since this Muslim Nigerian
student has committed zena, he has
regretted it. You have agreed it is
wrong. You have stopped it. So you don't
do it again. Ask for forgiveness.
Inshallah Allah will forgive you.
Regarding a question that should you be
flogged then only Allah will forgive
you. No it's not required. Allah also
says that the sin you do you keep it to
yourself. Keep it private. Don't make it
public. It is not allowed for you to
make your sin public. That's the reason
I did not even read your name. So if you
do some evil act, try and hide it.
Repent. If your evil act is known to the
public and if you go to a court of law
to a
judge, then the judge will give you
punishment. But if it's not known, if
it's personal, it's yours what you have
done, you have done wrong, keep it to
yourself, ask for forgiveness,
inshallah, forgive you. Yes, there have
been cases in the past when there were
lady companions of the prophet who
didn't want to take any chances and told
the prophet they did zena prophet said
go away come afterwards come after
delivery of the child later on then the
punishment was given and when some
people started cursing her the prophet
said the repentance of her if you
distribute in Madina it will be
sufficient for the full town of Medina
that means she was of that high level
that she wanted to take no chances that
she did a sin and she wanted punishment.
But generally you should not proclaim
your sin. You don't have to be punished
to be forgiven. If it's known to the
public and even in the court of law
normally there's a shar that if someone
goes and says okay fine they will say
are you sure and they try and such
things they delay and they give a
smaller punishment rather than the
penalty. So in your case also you ask
for forgiveness. Follow the five points.
Inshallah I'll forgive you. There's no
requirement of you to be flawed.
Inshallah I'll forgive you. See to it
that you repent and you do more good
deeds. What you have to do that if you
have done a sin see to it that you do
more good deeds beside doing the far of
your zakat. Give more charity besides
your normal far salah. You do more do
more sunnah. Do more of your. So when
you do evil you compensate by extra good
deeds besides the far more of the
sunnah. And then last question was how
can you be a better Muslim? See to it
that you are
oned that you are sure that you are oned
of Allah subhanaa tala. See to it that
you offer five times salah. Beside five
time salah even offer the mo and along
with it. See to it that you get up in
the last one third of night and pray.
very important. see to it that besides
giving zakat give a percentage of income
whether it be 10% whether it be 30% 40%
the more you give the better for you see
to it that you fast in the month of
Ramadan and besides the f of month of
Ramadan you also fast on the first nine
days of zijah and on the muharam the
fasting of ashur preferably the three
days 9th 10th and 11th of mam See that
you fast on the yam and if possible even
on Mondays and Thursdays see to it that
you increase your ibada not go on fudge
go for hajj and inshallah read the Quran
daily with translation inshallah you'll
be on and you'll see that every year you
keep on increasing your iada increasing
your sunnah so that you become a better
Muslim every time. Hope that answers the
question.